hey what's up guys welcome to the show
this week I'm really really honored to
spend some time with dr. John Demartini
now if you don't know dr. John Demartini
he's probably written more books than
most people have read and speaks all
over the world more than any other
speaker that I know is a fantastic
researcher and teacher so dr. John thank
you so much for having me on the show
thank you so just to begin with like
what is it that you do exactly because I
know that you're you're very very well
known for teaching and researching but
would for anyone that doesn't know who
you are what what's the thing that you
think you're most famous for I think you
said it yeah I love learning a lot sure
yeah and I've been doing it next month's
will be four to seven years that's
fantastic so you'll want to like the
OGIS of personal development and I just
had just a guy that's on a man on a
mission at last traveling the world
teaching and yeah it's been my dream
since I was 17 you were involved with
the secret on the film yeah they there
was a number of people that were in film
to that yeah and I was definitely one of
them and that was Beck guess about 12 13
years ago yeah and they have a fantastic
book I know you don't teach the exact
same way the secret teachers well
there's some things that you don't quite
agree with well I think that there was a
little bit less emphasis on prioritised
action right there's really congruent
with what you really value so you're not
setting up unrealistic expectations and
fantasy yeah but some of the principles
about using our mind to stay focused and
to achieve I think is solid but there's
some polishing that I think most of
speakers on the secret we're blessed to
go out and yeah secret behind the secret
left out a secret cast oh right okay so
tell me how you talk about how to be
inspired and I kind of had the pleasure
of listen listening to you speak just
last week and it was really fascinating
what we ought your method of being
inspired which is doing what you love
talk to me a little bit about that well
every human being lives with a set of
priorities set of values things that are
most at least important in their life
yeah that is unique and fingerprints
to them and whatever's highest on the
value list of the value structure in
their lives they are spontaneously
inspired from within to fulfill them
into hacked apart right and whatever's
lower on the values they require
gradually more extrinsic motivations to
do it
punishments if they don't do it rewards
if they do kind of thing yeah
if you require external motivation to
get you to do what you say is important
what you say is important is it
important because what's really
important you spontaneously do and
finding what that is each individual
yeah and structuring your life by
priority according to that yeah helps
illuminate and in a sense inspire the
individual to do things with incremental
momentum building achievements so giving
yourself permission to do what's truly
meaningful to you yeah but you can't
wait to get up in the morning and do
what your life dedicates is truly
inspiring to you and structuring your
life by priority delegating lower part
of things to stick to high priority
things yeah and not letting external
derivative sources on the outside
influence or distract that there's a key
to building up amazing to you
I think it's a great way to live isn't
it doing what you love doing and doing
what you're called to do so do you think
if you having to try and drum up
motivation to do something that you
shouldn't be doing it well motivation is
a symptom never a solution right and
even though I get called sometimes on
media interviews or whatever you know
motivational speaker yeah I'm not a
motivational speaker a motivational
speaker somebody's using rhetorical
persuasion punishments and they're
creating a pain if you don't do
something in the yeah if you do
something in order to get you to do
something that they want you to do I'm
an inspired educator trying to help
people find out what it drives then yeah
educate them on how to live an inspired
life yeah so they don't require
motivation in their lives yeah I don't
require how would someone be much like
me okay how would I be motivated to get
in shape because I don't want to go to
the gym and I don't want to eat really
well so how do you get inspiration to do
that because you can't just say I'm not
aspire to do therefore I'm not going to
do it
well you delegate it how do you delegate
that
I'm gonna enjoy my minute well if you
set a goal yeah that is not aligned in
congruent with what you really truly do
value right and then you procrastinate
hesitating frustrated on the actions mmm
you'll tend to stuff depreciate to let
you know you're setting goals in on
authentic okay and so it'll be like me
saying I'm gonna start cooking yeah I
haven't cooked since I was 24 right
and I haven't driven a car in 30 years
you know you know bone disease eye eye
well you're born to do what is inspiring
to you specifically but but that's not
what is inspiring to me right any time I
do something lowering my values I do
that myself
any time I do things higher advice I
value myself yeah so I've learned to
delegate everything except what I love
doing
so I don't do anything except let the
things I'm inspired to do on a database
research I travel teach so everything
else I've given to other specialists
that love doing that yeah and so if you
are not really inspired and don't have a
dream to do it right now that's not on
your values yeah you'll beat yourself up
if you expect yourself to do that every
day you go work for me what am I not
doing it why are you sabotage can you
change your values now that's the that's
the solution if all of a sudden you knew
that you loved doing these these podcast
yeah
and all of a sudden I came to you and I
said let's ask the question how could
working out and a gym and eating
moderately and wise foods how
specifically could that help you expand
your podcast to global billion people
right and if I link to enough
associations to that outcome yeah showed
you examples of people you gave a lot of
appreciation to and show what they did
and stacked up enough benefits to doing
it where you knew that would be every
time you did a show yeah by eating
wisely and doing a little bit of work
out there's another many dollars in your
pocket I'll be willing to bet you do it
yeah that makes sense your values right
I just got to be shifted to your back so
anything that's linked to higher values
goes up in value yeah
and anything
up enough advantages to goes up and die
because every decision your back is paid
to what you believe at that moment with
the information you have of what will
give you the greatest advantage of a
disadvantage yeah so unless you perceive
way more advantages and working out
doing that then doing the podcast and
doing whatever else you're doing yeah
you're not gonna do it sure so how do
you figure out your values because it's
a very really important tonight values
is very important so how do you figure
it out well on my website dr. DiMartino
dot-com I've got a 13 step questionnaire
yeah that's complimentary it's free for
people it's private
no one's gonna see it with them but they
have to be really integral and honest
about the answers they can't lie to
themselves right
yeah look at what your life really
objectively dinner you know look at your
life objectively and look what is it
really demonstrated yeah but it's it's
how do you fill your space because you
find you fill your space where things
are valuable too mmm just like a little
baby in a in a little crib or whatever
if you put something in that little crib
and it the baby likes it it'll put in
its mouth and I'll keep it close to it
yeah if doesn't like it and toss it get
rid of it yeah well humans don't like
things that are low in value near them
they're like things that are valuable to
them close to them yeah so how do you
figure space you make time find time
spend time for things that are valuable
to run out of time for things in art I
run out of time for going to the gym I'm
not a gym guy yeah a little calisthenics
and push-ups on the database but that's
it so I don't have time for that don't
make time for things that alone my guy
is but I've made tiny other things that
are important yeah then I look at where
I'm where I'm most energized because
when you're doing high value things your
energy goes up you know a little party
things low value things energy strength
yeah and a bit people ask you all the
time about they say how do you how do
you keep up the energy to do all the
speeches that you do and how do you find
time to research but it's easy to do it
because you absolutely love doing it
right that's it I mean I every minute I
have I'm looking at new new materials
yes I was researching new things on
cancer today and researching them on all
kinda stairs but I I love learning so
nobody has to remind me to do it if
somebody has to remind you to do some
it's not what's really important to you
yeah you can lie to yourself because
sometimes you can subordinate other
people and think oh I wish I was like
and try to be like them and then try to
make those same act wrong but if it's
not really in your values unless you
change your values yeah you know beat
yourself up yeah so then you look at how
you what energize you then you look at
what you spend your money on you spend
money and quit your values your higher
are clear values dictate your financial
destiny so how do you spend your money
because you make money find money and
spend money on things that are valuable
and you won't for the others yeah then
you look at where you're organized where
you're ordered you look at what you
think about visualize and talk to
yourself about models about how you
really want your life that shows
evidence coming true so I knew that I
was 17 I want to travel the world and
teach my life shows evidence of it yeah
I also want to be international sex
symbol like you have to life has no
evidence of that right so those are
delusions and knowing the difference
between what's true what your life
demonstrates meaning that requires no
motivation and things that you talk
about you kind of get a little dopamine
high but you don't do anything about
yeah those are fantasies yeah then I
look at what inspires you what do you
talk to people about most because you
keep bringing a conversation to things
that are valuable to it wrong then I
have you look at what goals that you
persevere on and don't stop and you get
achieved because those are the ones that
are high on your values and then look at
what you spontaneously want to learn
about read about study about watch
youtube videos about yeah and if you
look at the common thread and all 13
questions it'll point you right in the
direction of what your life is
demonstrating I'm not interested in what
you say because that's usually not
accurate I look at what your life
demonstrates right that's what tells me
what you value could you light up your
hierarchy values is dictating your desk
is determine your perceptions decisions
and actions and your life is an
expression of that did your genius man
and you talked about how to get your
genius from within like there is no
actually how bothered are you about
money how bothered are you about money
how motivated are you to make money
well I set out to in my youth really
around age 28
yeah is what I decided I want to be
financially dependent right prior that I
would good at making money but I would
spend it but I decided that I was gonna
buy things that went up in value buy
assets not immediate gratifying
consumables the I appreciating in value
right so I made a goal I don't have it
as my highest
number four okay biocide if it was what
building I would be in a different
industry
I'd be managing money yeah but if I'm if
I'm I want to be a teacher and I want to
travel the world and I want to be
financially dependent and I wanted to
not do it because I had to I'd want to
do it because I love to write and so I
structured my life and saved and
invested a lot of my percentage of my
income yeah
towards that up to fifty three percent
of the gross income my business went
into investment what kind of things did
you invest in well I mainly started off
with the stock market right and then I
started buying properties and doing
rental properties and things of that
nature and then I started buying
individual companies so I've done a many
different habitats even did art and
things but most of mine had been in the
stock market and buying company the
company shares a company yeah ed most of
it because that way I can do passive
investing without having to do anything
right but but there's also very powerful
yeah wealthy people that buy great
properties and build huge portfolios
I've met some amazing people that built
billions of dollars today mmm you know
property investment because because
people sometimes like to me you know I'm
financially free property and they
wonder why I teach and it's just a love
it's just a passion and I think that I'd
probably be miserable if I wasn't if I
wasn't teaching and wasn't sharing well
it to me my wife used to say before she
passed away that you know you're doing
another seminar in your sleep
so day or night I'm doing a talk right
so I have a tendency to love you know
share any information that I learned mmm
when I learned to information I can't
wait to share yeah and I'm learning
every day so I can't wait to share when
you study in when you research in are
you what do you love more teaching or
researching so are you researching
thinking I can't wait to teach this or
do you research because you love
researching and then it spells out it's
both because if I am NOT able to do my
research I'm not keeping crying and not
afresh and so that's an important
essential component of what I do but at
the same time and learning so somehow
one way or the other I'm learning
through interviewing and interacting or
the other thing but I found that because
I've learned to speed readers if the
reading is very value
right if I could knock out a book very
quick and I can take the whole life of
somebody in not gonna add in hours less
so that's valuable for me but sharing
you also learn by sharing and teaching
because sometimes the things you
emphasize is also for you yeah yeah so
you're talking to yourself I think shift
yeah obviously said that most languages
for not only others but also so yeah so
we're teaching others what we're trying
to learn it helps us learn yeah and one
of the things that fascinates me about
about your teaching is you haven't got
like a message and then become bang bang
bang on that message you've written how
many books anyway you know I don't know
I have to get him up it's a lot it's a
lot I've been scrolling through and yes
if I looked at all the books and manuals
and textbooks or anything else it's it's
a lot so in so many topics speed reading
values being been having gratitude being
inspired there's just so much what sure
what's your favorite thing to teach well
more recently because I've distilled a
lot of the work that I've done down the
very formation and very foundation of
human behaviors values mmm-hmm
so a lot of my work revolves around
human values not values are as I said
what you perceive decide and act upon so
everything that goes on to people's life
is based on that so many people are
comparing themselves to other people
putting people on pedestals yeah
injecting their values inculcating their
ideas yeah trying to be somebody they're
not trying to envy and imitate others
and then wondering why they beat
themselves up and wondering why they're
not building momentum because they're
going after something that's inauthentic
and the feedback that the symptomatology
that occurs in their lives is trying to
get them to be authentic yeah to go to
what's really important to them and the
moment they do they start to excel they
build momentum and they they achieve
more so and they expand themselves and
wake up their natural-born leader which
I think in Haley innately everyone has
so getting clear what those are and
prioritizing your life if you don't feel
your day with high priority
to inspire your life fills up the low
priority distractions it don't and the
little party distracted to don't quote
on you the gang because I wasn't that
was a better brilliant quote say that
again if you don't feel your day with
high priority actions that inspire you
yeah
your day fills up in low party
distractions it's a nice cry and if you
don't feel your day with challenges yeah
that inspire you your day fills up a
challenge that don't and challenge the
doughnuts bio crate distress but
challenge that do inspire you creates
you stress which is wellness promoting
and activates creative genius innovation
and original ideas did we create our
genius under challenge not support its
the challenges that we are inspired to
conquer there's a new little movie in
Netflix
Bill Gates and he's going out and trying
to find the problems of the world and
how to solve them to me that's what
leaders do yeah they don't try to avoid
challenges they go and search for the
biggest challenge that they can
contribute to and make a difference yeah
focus on ingeniously creatively creating
original ideas that serve those that's
great that's great so ok practically
speaking then what does this look like
well on a daily basis I I had the
opportunity cost 34 years ago to speak
to Mary Kay Ash and her team a thousand
five hundred girls yeah so I was in
heaven that day I had sex symbol yeah it
was well I was the only guy in the room
I think and there's nothing but a bunch
of beautiful women there and at the end
of my talk I had the opportunity to meet
with Mary Kay Ash and this was in Dallas
Texas at the Anatole hotel complex and
resort complex her convention complex at
the end I asked her what advice could
you give a young aspiring speaker mmm
because at the time I was probably 31
I'm 65 now so I said I said what advice
can you give a young man and she said
every day write down the six or seven
highest priority actions you can do
today that if you did those actions
you'd be fulfilled and do those every
day just the actions for the day not
project to take we ask that actions for
the day
under projects and do them and at the
end of the day reward yourself by
whatever it means to reward you in my
case I started putting money extra money
the savings from our investments so I
did that and I kept on index cards 3x5
index cards yeah so I carried in this
card to me and I looked at it throughout
the day and I'm taking off as the
priorities are being done yeah
if I find out that I'm done at two
o'clock I add another priority tick it
off if I still have another few hours
I'll put another one in there not go
over run where you fell into Jess
cheon's from overwhelming gold numbers
but just high priorities for the deck
highest party things and then I take the
cards and I'd stack them day by day day
by day in the chronological order and
then one at a time I went back and I
went through that list of cars I think
there's a nearly 100 car or thousand car
to most and over a few years and and
then the process of doing that I I
looked at what was the most common
things that were highest priority mmm
and I I took them made this massive list
of what were the priorities on the first
card toss the card second card there was
a couple overlaps toss the card right
and after a while I kept seeing line
line line line slash line line line so I
kept repeating yeah and so I looked at
which one out of 700 cards or so which
one shot at most frequent second most
frequent third was freakin fourth most
frequent and it was research right
travel teach alright so once I did that
I said okay everything else is delegated
yeah I'm gonna get everything off my
plate I'm not going to do anything but
what inspires me and cried is heist a
party and the self-worth goes up the
opportunity to up business opportunity
my life flourished by living by pride
what do you what do you think to people
that say you know support to have a
work-life balance and they might be so
obsessed with their business or their
job and that they're trying to
desperately make time for home life like
what kind of advice would you give those
folks oh there's a lot of them well it
depends on the individual there's no
rules you know many people are caught in
rules about how it's supposed to be you
know you should have three hours of the
family in three hours with this and
three hours of this in two hours you
know there's no rules so you have to be
honest with yourself about what your
values are yeah and realize if you try
to live in other people's rules you'll
probably beat yourself up if they can
you know this isn't fulfilling yeah
conformity is not the same as the
normally that normally comes from living
congruently by your values some people
have a very high value on family some
people don't some people have a very
high value on spirituality some people
don't some people have a high value on
business and wealth some people don't
mmm I know people that are dedicated to
sports and there's been a yogi a friend
of mine is a physicist and yogi loves
his mind and he loves his body and he
works out and he looks great he's yeah
he's something years old and he's always
made just enough money to get by and
he's never had financial rewards that
way but he's doing what he loves every
day and he's looking bright and he's
probably gonna lived about 100 so
everybody's got a different set of
values and fulfillment is living
congruently by what your values are not
companion to somebody else and expecting
it to be some other box mm-hmm so
work-life balance is based individually
on that individual in my particular case
I feel that I was I'm traveling and I'm
speaking by getting my social life met
because I under act with thousands that
soluble I did my business but my
intellectual stimulus yeah spiritual
inspiration yeah they're part of my
family yeah I feel like this is part of
my family my genetic family is also with
me my daughter's traveling with me many
times and this one was just in Tokyo
with me right so I got a mixture of all
different forms and it's my mixture yeah
it's not somebody else's somebody else
would look at that to go on I could
never do that yeah I'm not here to live
your life I'm here to live my life just
warming you so do what you love and then
figure out how to get paid handsomely to
do it but the thing is don't you think
that usually even it's let's say you
love cutting peoples hair if you want to
get paid handsomely to do it all totally
you've got to be a good business person
and you're probably going to end up not
going peoples hair you're going to be
running the business not necessarily you
may end up having amazing cutting of
hair and being an icon out in the hire
industry and higher quality manager to
run a massive industry of hair salons
but I have a friend that has hair salon
yeah I have a guy that has a sandwich
shop he's got a tea sandwich shops
wrong he's not a businessman he just
hires people to do that but do you not
think that you better off to just do
what's gonna make money and then and
then move with that money then do what
you love rather than trying to kill two
birds with one stone you don't think
that's like you destined to fail
go and make money without meaning
debauchery is the result in your
amygdala if you go out and do something
with meaning you end up with
philanthropy there's a difference you
can be the wolf on Wall Street yeah and
end up in debauchery yeah
or you can be a Bill Gates or with
philanthropy because that trying to
solve problems they're trying to solve
problems that are meaningful and inspire
them yeah that's what I recommend yeah
making money without a meaning now if
you can find a way of doing something
you love and do something that serves
vast numbers of people there you got to
win what about if you just love business
you just love it doesn't matter what the
product is she doesn't love business but
your system is in place and and and
making money if you if you love building
business and love making money and
that's what you love doing it yeah yes
then those businesses that are viable
that serve but but you're not gonna be
able to do that without meeting people's
needs no and you're not gonna do it with
zest and inspiration yeah a consistently
if it doesn't meet your needs you're one
of the top business consultants on the
world problem oh you can sort a lot of
very large high-end businesses what do
you think what do you think most
business is what's that what's that
biggest struggle well the leader itself
has to be clear in the mission
information if there's no clarity you
don't first there has to be clarity I I
recently worked with a very large steel
company in America
yeah and that gentleman and just
chatting with a CEO of that company the
vision the clarity of that man is why
he's worried that
yeah the clarity wrong clear what it is
unwavering focus on that and again
that's crying so I think that when
you're living in your executive Center
whenever you're living by highest
priority your blood glucose and oxygen
goes into the forebrain the forebrain
has inspired vision strategic planning
executing plans and self-government yeah
and it sets GABA and glutamate
transmitters down into the amygdala and
calms down impulses and instincts that
distract you from being present and
focused on a mission so in an individual
is my highest party and they know
themselves their highest value their
identity revolves around it and they
know that they keep on it and stay
focused on it and let nothing stop them
they build unstoppable amendment yeah
that's awesome I mean what about when
you invest do you only invest in what
you love or do you invest to sit cookers
I mean I'm a property investor if I
invested in houses that I loved I
probably won't make any money so I
that's the important plane to buy the
house and you're gonna live in the house
it's an investment it's not exactly so I
don't have to buy houses that you feel
will meet needs yes if the majority of
people wrong you need to be near school
need building a hot guy near beer thing
yeah go where the greatest amount of
needs yeah look the west of the web the
great book by Hubert help any crop you
know the book of wealth which I was
blessed to get a copy of it showed very
clearly there were three things to
wealthy people they were felt by divine
providence in human sovereignty that
they were here to serve ask numbers of
people yeah
which meant to meet the needs of the
highest values of people throughout the
world yeah in the vast or the number of
the greater the the potential resource
they to they also felt that they would
do whatever they could to raise the
standard of people in society yeah
anything that would really just you know
why would they do it is that because
they want to have just fancy art and
show off their art no that because they
want to have the best you know furniture
or the greatest cars whatever
no they they learned that they were
dedicated to rewarding people they
created original creative inspirational
anything mmm
they were investing in inspiration yeah
and not rest in desperation solving
problems does not rest in desperation
rest in desperation is robbing people of
dignity accountability responsibly and
productivity but investing in
inspiration is investing in leaders in
different fields that catapults us
further in social development and then
what happens that raises the standard
for everybody to keep going yeah and it
expands the economic markets so that's
what they found and the third one was
that they had transcended the morality
about money
if money is good and you're addicted to
it you end up undermining with
speculations if money is bad you're
avoided mmm but if money is neither good
nor evil and it's simply a measuring
mechanism of services rendered
yeah with fair exchange now you've got
something that's a waiting to yeah so so
powerful it's really interesting I mean
I I grew up very much
Christian family as a teenager I be you
know became very connected to my church
and gave my life to Jesus and had a
really spiritual experience which was
great and I'd open the back and I still
Christian but as a result of that I
ended up feeling really guilty about
being a businessman and I felt quite
judged in my church at times am i
certain Christians and they would say
you know to earn more than you need is
greed and and you can't you can't make a
you know you if you make a lot of money
you've trampled over the poor to do it
and it was a real battle for how to
really struggle with that well that's
that's probably a delusion yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna break that delusion yeah
do it okay when I wrote how to make one
hell of a profit still good to have
enough respect for that by the way yeah
I tried to break that if you're if
you're in a state where you're
exaggerating yourself and prod yeah and
you project your values on to your
employees and on to your customers and
you think you know better than they do
about what their needs are and you're
not caring to find out what their values
are and needs and values and needs are
you'll end up with an autocrat doing a
tremendous amount of motivation which
erodes the potential profit and no one
wants to buy until you're humbled
probably before the fall right if you're
minimizing yourself altruistic could
because if accumulated shame because
you've compared yourself to other people
and thought I'm not worthy you'll
sacrifice altruistically profits and
there's no money no profits but if you
have equity where you and your customer
and your employees are all working to
maximize fair and equitable sustainable
exchange in the world transactions that
are actually equitable then everybody
wants to continue doing business with
each other it's going equity third and
so what happens you have to care enough
about the employees and care enough
about the customers to know what their
needs are to continually keep abreast of
their changing values and meeting those
needs yeah yeah same with employees yeah
because nobody goes to work for the sake
of the company to go to work to fulfill
what their values are wrong and this
nobody goes to a company they're not
loyal to a company they're going where
they're getting two values men so if you
forget that and lose sight of that for
yourself or then and don't keep those in
equilibrium you undermined growth
financially in business so it's
interesting what that leads to is
equanimity within yourself neither pride
nor shame but equanimity true
authenticity and it leads to equity
between you and others not judgment
so you're transcending judgment and
you're in
state of equanimity which is the
spiritual path that is the essence of
spirituality so what he's saying is if
you're running a successful company
you're actually fulfilling a spiritual
mission right whereas a lot of people
don't see like that well they've been
taught by the construct that some
religious people in Christianity no
absolutely Christianity of Christ but
some of the PAI had developed in it yeah
the institutionalization mean that is
more blessed to give them to receive but
something think about that if it's more
blessed to give than receive then the
person is receiving is cursed because
they're not getting to give yeah yeah
the truth is it's more blessed that fair
exchange if you do a service and
somebody pays you less than what you
feel it's worth and you're what you
agreed to you're not gonna wanna do
business with them and if you feel that
you gave them more than service and they
didn't pay you enough you're not gonna
want your business for them mmm
so Nature has a way of making sure that
there's a equitability and fair exchange
and yeah a thermostat in our intuition
to get there yeah I know that's what's
sustainable so that true spirituality is
a state of equanimity which transcends
judgment which is the spiritual path you
even said I don't want to miss quaver
I'm pretty sure you said if you pour
your selfish well I didn't say it that
way I said I'm pretty sure you did I
said look if you're yes close if you're
poor you're probably not caring about
humanity all that's wrong yeah you're
probably not thinking about their needs
so I'd say if you pull and you're not
making money probably you're not helping
enough people you're probably not caring
about their needs to try to find a way
of doing something that you can confirm
is valuable to them because they'll
they'll pay for it because ultimately
money will only follow value or for so
long unless you're tricking people well
this morning I had a webinar from around
the world and there were some people
coming on there that were new in the
journey of business yeah and they were
thinking about how do I make money and I
said money is made by serving people
yeah that simples that absolutely I
don't make money unless I'm feeling
somebody's fulfilled me no but it's even
the same in the property business you
need to provide the right accommodation
people say to me are you screwing people
over because you rent in high and you're
buying love but actually it's to say
you're providing good affordable
accommodations people you buying
if you're giving them something that
they need that you hatches their names
you're serving on it yeah and then you
get rewarded from that yeah so when
somebody says I can't afford things that
means that they're either exaggerating
what they think they need
narcissistically and spending more than
they actually have and not caring about
other people yeah what more they're
basically sacrificing for other people
altruistically because of shame shame
leads to the altruism and pride leads to
the narcissism but love leads to
equilibrium so I tell people I said you
know if you really really care I was
speaking at a at a church I think it was
in i/o Iowa and there was a minister
there that was struggling to keep the
church going and I said to me he brought
me back I was about to speak that day
yeah at this church tonight and I said
if you're struggling it's because you're
not you're you've not filled with the
spirit and you're not inspiring and
you're not leading to filling people
values Wow and then he goes and his
assistant was there going yeah like yeah
get it is it truth you talk yeah I said
I said so what's really inside you that
you want to share and one of these
people need yeah let's go find out what
the people need yeah and the second he
did 400 more people came into this
church incredible on a Sunday so yeah he
was now meeting your needs the book
what's the book called let me Clemmy
it's called how to make a one hell of a
prophet and still get to heaven yeah
fantastic book yeah I wrote I was
walking down Madison Avenue get ready to
go to an Italian restaurant one night
and my wife is sort of there and I was
on my way there from a meeting a consult
and you know and it just popped in my
head that title because I realize it's
so many people lots of people have an
internal conflict because we the
religious instruction or social in you
know
conformity yeah that I mean you got to
realize that if 99% of the population
doesn't have financial independence hmm
so that means if you're surrounding
yourself with people that are average
that are not financially able and you're
inculcating some of their belief systems
and their ideas it's easy to not want to
be rejected fit into those beliefs that
lead you not to financial freedom it's
interesting as well because your story
is really powerful because you weren't
born you know in lots of wealth and I
know you had a speech impediment and
used to
studies do you think anyone can be
successful and the way that you have or
do you think that some people are just
born more intelligent and more genius
than other people well I don't know what
to label myself successful I just label
myself a man on a mission
yeah other people putting all kind of
labels of success or whatever entity but
yeah I have to tell a story if you don't
mind go ahead I was teaching a speed
reading class alright because I didn't
know how to read when I was young I
didn't read till he's 18 but once I
learned I really really wanted to learn
and I tried to go faster and faster to
learn more and so people started to see
that and they said what can you teach us
what you're doing and I started kind of
teaching classes about by the time I
went on to professional school I had a
normal kind of formal every term
semester I taught this class because I
wanted to class well this one time I was
teaching in my apartment about 25 people
in my department and there's a guy there
that was partly blind definitely
definitely barely could hear and barely
could speak properly because he was deaf
and he came in there with an eyeglass a
special eyeglass on top of a glass so
you could really focus and he had to
look at one letter at a time almost a
little bitty two syllables at a time and
he came in here to come and do my speed
reading course so in my mind I was
prejudging him yeah I thought I don't
know if this guy's gonna pull it off
well I didn't want to discourage him but
I didn't really think he was gonna do
this yeah so he did this and he didn't
do well in that first time but the
second time I did it again I did the
class again a five four months later and
there was again but this time he's
moving along pretty good and I thought
wow that's really amazing you must have
worked at this he said I work at least
three hours a day on this and then the
next time I did the class he was there
again but this time he's faster than
anybody in the room Wow
when I finally graduated from
professional school he asked me if I
would honor him with continuing teaching
the class at the school now this
gentleman right now is a professional
speaker traveling the world around the
world as a professional speaker and he's
got special eyeglass systems today and
he's overcome his speech impediment and
his in his funnel thing and he gets
special hearing aids everything
he's a professional speaker they and I
underestimated his capacity to do things
yeah so sometimes the people you think
would never have it it's not what you
start from it's not what you go through
it's how articulate you're clear on what
you want and is how aligned it is with
what you value most because when you
have a high value on it you won't let
anything in the world stop you from it
yeah and that's what you do what you do
yeah yeah that's awesome well John I
really appreciate your time yes thanks
for coming on the show if people want to
learn more about you and maybe you tend
some of your classes
I mean I'd highly recommend it how do
they do that they just simply go to dr.
V Virginia comm it's an educational
website to probably keep busy the rest
of life
I'm betting well there's hundreds and
hundreds of interviews and articles and
media and youtubes and all kind of
things thanks so much thank you guys I
hope you enjoyed that check check out
the website what was it again dr. D
martini calm dr. D martini calm I hope I
hope you found that really inspiring all
I'm probably going to go back and watch
that a few times and just take some of
it in subscribe stay tuned see you next
time
[Music]